all across this fair nation people who
are self isolating are discovering
virtual concert streaming television
shows and listening the podcast if they
haven't discovered them already Dan
Ackerman senior managing editor with our
partners at C net joins us now from his
home in Vermont
he's got the Civil War beard going away
in the country you might as well get the
beard to go with it you know I think a
lot of what we're doing is we're leading
into things that we've already had
before which is those streaming services
Netflix Disney Plus Amazon Prime video
Apple TV Plus and really discovering a
lot of the shows that are on there
binging them but also finding new things
to I think it's super interesting that a
lot of movie companies are now taking
first-run movies and putting them online
because otherwise they're just gonna
burn the theatrical release and lose
their window so things like birds of
prey and the new Invisible Man movie and
Aundre that's a big Pixar movie all
coming straight to streaming skipping to
theaters which is really what they have
to do right now I love this idea but you
know there are a lot of events happening
DJ nice had a great dance party the
other night stars are giving concerts so
what can we do how is technology helping
us feel less isolated I mean we have all
the streaming and connectivity we could
ever need everyone is doing zoom
meetings we just did a zoom happy hour
at my office we also use that for
regular meetings occasionally my son is
having zoom playdates with his friends
you get six with him up on the screen at
the same time all putting different fake
backgrounds behind them and it's an is
hilarious so I think a lot of the social
isolation is being cured not just by
one-way communication where somebody
like John Legend or Rob Thomas does a
little streaming concert from home and
you watch it but also by two-way
communication where we're literally just
having video chats like you'd never
thought you were just casually do for
fun not just for work you know and also
communicating through things like online
games online game services whether it's
fortnight or Call of Duty warzone or
anything else they let your voice chat
and even video chat at the same time
yeah and let us not forget about CBS all
access I'm on episode 8 of Picard and
you also have the whole backlog of Star
Trek
for kids though our younger viewers
parents need help what do you got then I
found it's fantastic it's fascinating
that a bunch of the authors that my son
loved like Mo Willems and a bunch of
other people are doing live readings or
live drawing tutorials often through
Twitter or through Facebook video and
and they just get on and they show you
how to do something or they'll just read
you from their books and and that's a
great way to keep kids busy although I
find especially for school-aged kids
they're pretty busy anyway because a lot
of the schools that are out have Google
classroom set up so you have to show
them how to use a Chromebook or a
similar laptop get them signed in and
they give them a full day worth of
school work which is frankly pretty
fantastic I know Dan I found myself so
disconnected I just reached out and said
could I be in your zoom meeting today
and I'm not even part of the group
because I want people to talk to in the
apartment during the day but do you do
it but do you do a funny background I
know creativity and imagination there's
lots to choose from these days thank you
Dan Ackerman David Letterman giving him
the key before as money looks like thank
you very much the hibernation beard
there you go and to learn what we and
our colleagues like head over to cBS
This Morning Calm